inting them and that's exactly what
you're trying to do no because you're
trying to Inc
[Applause]
I when you are brought up believing that
you're the best due to your tribe thank
you due to your ethnicity due to your
biology due to your genetics due to your
DNA deep
racism this actually comes out in the
clip that we just saw I'm a Jew and I'm
your boss yeah could it be the case that
you're saying that because he's a
gentile yes could it be the case that
you're saying cuz it's go because he has
to serve
you just imagine the people back in the
day when they would have to travel
certain distances for months or even
years what is one thing that they would
carry with them the Quran why because
they did not have it on their mobile
devices or their gadgets brothers and
sisters imagine you have a app the Quran
app which not only shows you how much
rewards you get but reminds you to read
the Quran gives you reminders download
the app now and let it testify for you
on your that you read it wherever you
was how are you guys doing recently
there's been an individual called Ezra
levent who you've had experience with
haven't you Alie yeah we both have we
don't need to speak to don't give you a
life story both of you have either of
you met him no we haven't we tried to
track him down when the whole attack
Tommy Tommy he was connected to Tommy he
was he was working Tommy Robinson was
working for him he was working a
Canadian but now Tommy's in prison isn't
he yeah yeah
yeah anyway even Katy Hopkins is working
for him as well really yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah well what happened
with him is that he recently attended in
a Palestinian protest he came in acting
all arrogant and a counter protest I
want to watch this video with you guys
and then come back and respond
interesting he said something very uh
interesting yeah let's take at it wait
they can't hear you Ali say that again
he said something very interesting watch
it now oh okay
well yeah because you're inciting this
crd
Andes inting them and that's exactly
what you're trying to do I'm a Jew no
because you're trying to incite them I
haven't tried to in them I want you take
a picture of the hate crime that you're
on the other side you didn't need to
walk
over now I'm going to tell you to move
over
there I allowed you to take I you to
take that so you're refusing to leave
I'm refusing to leave why because I'm a
Jew I'm a citizen and I'm your boss and
I don't leave say Jews on you know what
stre in the interest of keeping peace
here and Public Safety you're under
arrest foring
[Applause]
the okay from okay just from little
little that I know of him and following
the far right in this dirt bag here um
this is their tactic you see Tommy
robbert do the same thing they go on
purpose provoking they go look the
police asking him why did you come to
this side they do it on purpose they get
arrested and then they say the
establishments against us donate it's
the same strategy used by Tommy Robinson
and Tommy is his boss he makes him go
and do these things which is stupid if
you go to a counter protest to be the
victim player exactly you provoke them
on purpose get arrested the establish is
against us please donate same strategy B
what I don't understand is that why did
he you know connect yes why did he feel
the need to say I'm a Jew and I'm your
boss like why did he connect those two
things together the iron is isn't that
antisemitic to say I'm your boss like
are you trying to say like you guys
control everything what do you mean by
that to be honest with you oh
whoa where is this going Ali yeah well
I'll tell you what it could be going I
me let's be honest there are some um
passages of the talmud which indicate
the low lowly nature of let's say the
Gentiles or the this actually comes out
in the clip that we just saw I'm a Jew
and I'm your boss yeah could it be the
case that you're saying that because
he's a gentile yes could it be the case
that you're saying because it's go
because he has to serve you because in
your talmood or your parents or maybe
some other people have taught you this
thing could it be the case I don't think
it's far off to say that this could be
the case and this as I say it's not just
Zionism this is Judaism okay I'm not
saying all Jews have the same belief
system yeah of course but I'm saying
this is in the books I think you know
you know what's very interesting is that
you you know that uh Ezra event is a
hardcore Zionist and the thing that
they're trying to purport and put
forward is that Zionism equals Judaism
yeah that if you critique Zionism you're
critiquing Jews and you're critiquing
the religion of Judaism what's very
interesting is you see people like Ezra
Levant Ben Shapiro who are trying to
forward this notion and trying to really
push this I.E making it something all of
these people are anti-semites they hate
Jews and Judaism this is not the case at
all and he knows exactly what he's doing
he's going there and he's using the term
Jew and then he got exactly what he
wanted people don't care that man was
unfaced bro the fact that he got
arrested he got what he wanted from
there and he's going to run back and say
oh it was because I was a Jew and this
and that doesn't work anymore but but
that's but that's the point and that's
why schul alone who also won the Israel
2000 prize she said anti-Semitism what
anti-Semitism we use it to quash any
criticism against isra that's right and
this is a woman who's been recognized
within Israel good so I mean we know
exactly what he's doing what he's doing
is he's trying to take away legitimate
criticism of a
colonizer a country or a state that
practices illegal
settlements apartheid genocide whatever
thing you can think of is being
committed in Israel and he is trying to
now shift the gold posts shift it no no
no no it's Judaism and Jews no Judaism
and Jews predate Zionism that's predate
Israel you know what I mean it's true
absolutely bro it's fantastic yeah yeah
I mean there's nothing much to say about
like you guys have said as well like
many instances you see it throughout
this war this attitude of and it's very
interesting because it shows me how much
further the Quran is a miracle from
Allah because Allah I've always said
Allah talks about the psychology of the
Pagan Arabs uh the Jews the Christians
some Muslim Muslims Allah talks about
that Allah tells you about the
psychology of different group not all of
them same so the point here is though
that the fact that Allah talks about
them saying we're going to go hell but
we're not going to stay but for a couple
of days it just shows this arrogant
attitude and then when someone's
arrogant and entitled they make stupid
statements like this and that was one of
them and yeah absolutely right he's we
he's trying to weaponize the religion
for his own political gain he's been
doing this since day one he hires the
likes of Katy Hopkins and Tommy Robinson
and the ab people that are hardcore
islamophobe Zionist he is the scum of
the scum and now he's using this
religion to get a larger pay packet you
make her sick you sickening individual
you tell them you tell them and the
endite cart is not working anymore and
well done to that police officer who
didn't give a damn did not give a damn
he was unfazed by it all and he put him
in
cuffs made him like a caged animal
really yeah exactly like a caged animal
really well
just imagine the people back in the day
when they would have to travel certain
distances for months or even years what
is one thing that they would carry with
them the Quran why because they did not
have it on their mobile devices or their
gadgets brothers and sisters imagine you
have a app the Quran app which not only
shows you how much rewards you get but
reminds you to read the Quran gives you
remind us download the Quran app now and
let it testify for you on your that you
read it wherever ever you was